Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich bin einverstanden. Aber Frau Doktor, ich habe große Probleme. Ich kann nicht Luft bekommen.
Sie können nicht Luft bekommen?
Genau. Können Sie mir den Gänsel helfen?
Okay, okay, okay. Wir werden jetzt gleich Ihre Sauerstoff-Sättigung messen und eine Sauerstoffmaske mit Sauerstoffmaske geben.
Frau Doktor, ich habe auch Brustschmerzen. Deswegen können Sie mir ...
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen?
Ja, ich habe auch Herzrasen.
Okay, okay, okay. Wir messen jetzt gleich Ihre Vitalparameter und führen gleich eine EKG durch.
Seit wann haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Seit einer Stunde habe ich es.
Seit einer Stunde. Und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, strahlen nicht aus, Frau Doktor.
Okay, das ist gut. Das ist ein guter Zeichen. Schöner Zeichen.
Aber wir werden sowieso auf jeden Fall eine EKG durchführen, Ihre Vitalparameter messen, Sauerstoff-Sättigung messen, damit wir sicher sein können, ob etwas nicht Schlimmeres, ob etwas nicht Notfalls gibt.
Okay.
Okay, okay. Also wir haben alles gemacht. Fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, ja, Frau Doktor, danke schön. Ich fühle mich ein bisschen besser.
Super, okay. Können wir jetzt am nächsten Mal das Aufnahmegespräch führen, damit Sie sich besser fühlen?
Ja, ja, vielen Dank.
Okay, super. Also zunächst benötige ich Ihre persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich bin Alfred Proch.
Alfred?
Proch.
Ja.
Können Sie Ihre Nachname kurz buchstabieren?
Okay. P-R-O-C-H. Proch.
Proch. Okay, Herr Proch. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Wie ist Ihre Geburtstätung?
5. März 1967.
Okay, 67. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1 Meter, 79 und ich wiege 105 Kilo, Frau Doktor.
105 Kilo, okay. Also Herr Proch, Sie haben seit einer Stunde Brustschmerzen.
Ohne Ausstrahlung.
Genau.
Haben Sie schon vorher unter ähnliche Beschwerden gelitten?
Nein, nein, Frau Doktor. Ich habe das erste Mal diese Beschwerde.
Also das erste Mal. Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Ja, ja, das ist plötzlich aufgetreten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
7 oder 8, Frau Doktor.
8. Okay. Und wie ist es jetzt? Sie haben schon gesagt, dass es besser ist.
Aber wie würden Sie jetzt schätzen?
Zu schmerz kann ich 6 sagen.
6 sagen, okay. Auf jeden Fall besser.
Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben, Herr Proch?
Was meinen Sie, Frau Doktor?
Also sind die Schmerzen also stechend, drückend, krampfartig, bohrend, leicht?
Okay, dann stechend.
Manchmal sind sie stechend.
Okay. Sie hatten auch gesagt, dass Sie Luftnot haben.
Begleitet der Luftnot den Brustschmerzen oder hatten Sie es schon vorher?
Nein, nein, Frau Doktor. Meine andere Schmerzen, meine Schmerzen, haben zusammen bekommen.
Okay. Haben Sie auch Herzstolpern, Herzrasen bemerkt, gefühlt, verspürt?
Was bemerkt, Frau Doktor, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Während die Brustschmerzen aufgetreten haben, hatten Sie auch Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern bemerkt?
Ja, genau. Ich habe auch Herzrasen und zudem habe ich Husten, Frau Doktor.
Sie haben auch Husten? Ist das eine trockene Husten oder mit Auswurf?
Ja, das ist trocken, aber ich habe ein paar, zwei Mal Brut dabei gesehen.
Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Seit einer Stunde, Frau Doktor.
Seit einer Stunde. Okay, seit auch einer Stunde.
Okay. Herr Puch, haben Sie vielleicht irgendeine Auslöser bemerkt für diese Beschwerden?
Ja, Frau Doktor, vor einer Stunde war ich bei der Arbeit und damals bin ich die Treppe gestürzt.
Also Treppe hochsteigen, also sind Sie von der Treppe gestürzt?
Nein, ich habe keine gestürzt, aber die Beschwerden sind aufgetreten, als ich die Treppe gestürzt habe.
Okay, kann man sagen, körperliche Belastung?
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja, die körperliche Belastung hat diese Beschwerden ausgelöst.
Okay, haben Sie sich damals während dieser körperlichen Belastung auch Schwindel gefühlt?
Ja, ich habe auch Schwindel gefühlt, Frau Doktor.
Sind Sie schon mal ohnächtig geworden?
Nein, denke ich nicht.
War es schwarz vor Ihren Augen?
Nein, nein.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich fieberig, Herr Broch?
Nein, Frau Doktor, ich habe keine Fieber.
Also Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Nachschweiß, haben Sie solche Beschwerden nicht?
Ich habe keine Nachschweiß, aber Frau Doktor, ich habe bemerkt, dass ich mehr, mehr schitze als früher.
Also generell oder nur seit einer Stunde?
Nur eine Stunde.
Also schwitzen Sie kalt oder fühlen Sie Hitzegefühl?
Ja, ich schwitze.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, vielleicht irgendwo anders auch Schmerzen bemerkt?
Nein, aber ich bin hier mit meinen Kollegen gekommen und es hat mir gesagt, dass meine Diebken blau geworden sind.
Ist bei Ihnen irgendwelche Herzerkrankungen bekannt, Herr Broch?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Bluthochdruck.
Seit wie vielen Jahren?
Seit sieben Jahren.
Nehmen Sie schon etwas dagegen ein?
Ja, ich nehme dagegen Betalock-Sock ein jeden Tag.
Betalock-Sock. Wie viel Milligramm wissen Sie die Dosierung?
Das ist 25 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie einmal morgens oder abends?
Ich nehme nur abends ein. Ist das richtig, Frau Doktor?
Also abends oder morgens nicht, aber wieviel Mal Sie täglich einnehmen, ist uns wichtig für die Dosierung.
Ist bei Ihnen noch andere Erkrankungen bekannt, chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, ich habe auch Bluthochdruck. Seit zwei Jahren.
Seit zwei Jahren. Und was nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ich nehme Januar ein, 100 Milligramm ein.
Wie bitte? Wie ist die Name der Medikamente?
Mit Januar.
Januar.
Mit uns.
Ok. Also können Sie nochmal aussprechen?
Januar.
Ok. Und wie viel Milligramm in welchem Dosis ist das?
100 Milligramm.
Wieviel Mal nehmen Sie täglich?
Nur morgens.
Ok. Seien noch welche Erkrankungen bekannt?
Nein, Frau Doktor.
Ok. Ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen fragen.
Herr Bruch, haben Sie auf ein enges Gefühl bemerkt? Verschönt?
Nein, Frau Doktor, ich habe kein enges Gefühl.
Haben Sie an Ihren Füßen oder an Ihren Beinen oder Arme, also Lehmungen, kribbeln bemerkt?
Frau Doktor, seit einer Stunde habe ich keine Veränderung.
Aber vor vier Wochen habe ich eine Operation gehabt aufgrund eines gebrochenen Beins.
Deswegen habe ich dort ein bisschen Schwellung. Aber das ist nichts Neues.
Ok. Also Sie haben am Bein eine Schwellung aufgrund der Operation.
Wo ist es ganz genau gebrochen? Also welche Beine, Unterschenkel oder Oberschenkel?
Ja, rechte Unterschenkel.
Rechte Unterschenkel aufgrund eines Unfalls?
Ja, Frau Doktor, damals hatte ich einen Ratsunfall. Und meine rechte Unterschenkel hat gebrochen.
Ok. Es tut mir leid zu hören.
Aus der Schwellung sind Sie aber gut?
Ja.
Ok. Also die Schwellungen sind ganz normal und im Laufe der Zeit werden sie auch weggehen.
Aber jetzt seit einer Stunde haben Sie außer dieser Schwellung vielleicht Kribbeln, Lehmungen, Kraftverlust, Muskelschwäche bemerkt an Ihren Beinen oder Arme?
Nein.
Ok. Ist bei Ihnen noch andere Operationen durchgeführt worden?
Außer dieser Knochenbruch?
Nein.
Ok. Und außer der Beloxog und Janovir nehmen Sie noch andere weitere Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ich nehme keine anderen Medikamente, aber ich benutze eine selbe Wunde für diese Wunde.
Ok. Für Ihre Operation Wunde.
Ja. Genau.
Ok. Ist bei Ihnen Allergin bekannt, Herr Proch?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Ich habe keine Allergin.
Ok. Rauchen Sie, Herr Proch?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Ich rauche Schleider und ich rauche ca. 35 Zigaretten täglich.
35. Ok. Seit wie vielen Jahren?
Ca. 30 Jahre, Frau Doktor.
Schon seit langem her.
Ok. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nur an Mohanen trinke ich manchmal ein, manchmal zwei Becher Bier.
Bier, Bier.
Becher Bier. Ok.
Herr Proch, ich muss noch eine Frage vorstellen, aber nehmen Sie es bitte nicht persönlich an.
Das ist eine Routinfrage. Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein, nein, Frau Doktor.
Nein, super.
Treiben Sie Sport, Herr Proch?
Leider.
Sie treiben keine.
Ok. Sind Sie schon vollständig geimpft?
Ja, Frau Doktor.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein.
Super. Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Also bekannte chronische Erkrankungen an Ihren Vater, Mutter, wenn Sie haben Geschwister?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Mein Vater ist aufgrund Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Ach so. Es tut mir leid zu hören. Wie alt war er?
Damals war er 79 Jahre alt.
79?
Ja.
Ok.
Mein Mutter leidet an Brutgerinnungsstörungen.
Brutgerinnungsstörungen?
Ja.
Ok.
Also hat sie nur einmal oder mehrmals gelitten?
Wissen Sie, hat sie eine Brutgerinnungsstörung oder war es aufgrund einer Medikament oder vielleicht Rauchen oder Unbeweglichkeit?
Ich weiß nicht, Frau Doktor, warum diese Erkrankungen so sind.
Aber meine Mutter hat vielmals diese Probleme erlebt.
Und wie alt war sie, als sie am ersten Mal gelitten erlebt haben? Wissen Sie das?
Vielleicht ungefähr 40er Jahre, 50er Jahre. Was können Sie sagen?
Vielleicht ungefähr 60 Jahre.
60 Jahre?
Aber ungefähr, Frau Doktor.
Und in den 60er Jahren hat sie am ersten Mal erlebt?
Ok. Dann können wir eine Brutgerinnungsstörung ausschließen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Ok. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, Frau Bruch?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ok. Sie leben mit Ihrer Familie zusammen?
Genau.
Haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, Frau Doktor. Wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind alle gesund?
Ja.
Ok. Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie in der Baustelle arbeiten. Was machen Sie dort?
Baustelle? Ich habe nicht gesagt, Frau Doktor. Ich arbeite in einer Autoverkaufsfirma.
Ok. Warum habe ich das gedacht? Weiß ich nicht.
Sind Sie Büroangestellte?
Ja, man kann sagen.
Oder machen Sie eine belastbare Arbeit?
Nein, meine Arbeit ist nicht belastbar. Ich bin nicht ein Kunden.
Ok. Sie arbeiten schon im Büro?
Ja, man kann sagen.
Ok. Frau Bruch, das waren meine Fragen. Jetzt erstmalige Fragen. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, Frau Doktor. Aber ich habe Angst. Vielleicht kann ich mir meinen Vater den Impakt erleben.
Ja, das kann leider sein. Aber jetzt an dieser ersten Stelle, kümmern Sie sich nicht darum.
Wir haben unsere ersten Therapien durchgeführt. Mit den weiteren Therapien werden wir feststellen, ob es mit einer Herzkrankheit zu tun hat oder nicht.
Falls es auch mit Ihrer Vater zu tun hat, machen wir alles, was in unserer Macht steht.
Machen Sie sich erst keine Sorgen. Beruhigen Sie sich. Wir sind für Sie da.
Frau Bruch, ich muss kurz zu meinem Oberarzt. Aber ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen. Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Seit einer Stunde habe ich keinen Appetit, Frau Doktor.
Aber generell normal?
Normal, ja.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollte Gewichtsverlust?
Nein, ich habe nichts bemerkt.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Normalerweise kann ich ganz gut schlafen.
Okay, das waren nur kurze Fragen. Beruhigen Sie sich jetzt. Ich komme gleich wieder zurück, nachdem ich meine Oberarztbescheid gegeben habe.
Frau Doktor, soll ich im Martissenmarm warten?
Nein, Sie sind jetzt auf der Liege. Sie haben eine Sauerstoffmaske und Sie können sich hier beruhigen lassen.
Okay, falls Sie etwas möchten, können Sie den Schwester Bescheid geben.
Okay, bitte.
Ich komme gleich wieder zurück.
Okay.
Hatif, haben Sie eine Frage?
Ich habe heute die selbe Sache gemacht.
Ja, deswegen bin ich Konditor. Was sagen sie? Konditor, Konditorin?
Vielleicht gibt es eine unverfragene Frage.
Ich habe mich mit etwas beschäftigt, deswegen konnte ich mich nicht sehr aufrufen.
Okay.
Ich werde die nächsten zwei Tage mit Herrn Zehra beantworten.
Okay, ich werde das machen.
Ja?
Haben Sie seit vier Wochen nach der Operation Probleme? Oder wie viele Tage sind Sie nicht bewegt oder bleiben?
Herr Doktor, gute Frage. Nach der Operation musste ich eine Woche im Krankenhaus bleiben und noch eine Woche zu Hause im Bett bleiben.
Okay, seit wann arbeiten Sie? Angefangen zu arbeiten?
Seit zwei Wochen.
Seit zwei Wochen?
Ja.
Okay, Sie haben eine Woche im Krankenhaus geblieben und eine Woche zu Hause. Ja, okay.
Okay, jetzt, okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Aspirin oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Wie lange wird es mit Aspirin verschrieben?
Okay.
Herr Bruch, haben Sie an der geschwollenen Beine auch Überwärmungen oder Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, nein, Herr Doktor. Ich habe keine neue Änderungen bemerkt.
Wie gesagt, nach der Operation habe ich eine Wunde und eine kleine Wunde.
Das ist ein bisschen Schwierigkeit und Rötung, aber sehr klein.
Also es gibt schon eine Rötung, eine neue Rötung oder?
Nein, nein, nach der Operation habe ich das.
Okay. Ist es eine schmerzhafte Schwellung?
Ist es schmerzhaft oder?
Das ist sehr leicht geschmerzen.
Vielleicht kann ich Operation besagen, ja.
Operation habe ich.
Okay.
Ich vermute, dass Sie nach der Operation eine Analgetik benutzen.
Ja, Sie haben.
Während der Analgetik nehmen Sie regelmäßig Magerschutzmittel?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich nehme nicht regelmäßig.
Wenn ich brauche, dann nehme ich.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Herr Hatice, wenn Sie die Anleitung benutzen,
dann benutzen Sie nicht den Begriff der Anleitung, sondern den Begriff der Anleitung.
Ich benutze etwas, aber es gibt einen Begriff, um einen Schuss zu machen.
Okay, ich benutze einen Begriff.
Und dann gibt es auch einen Begriff, um einen Schuss zu machen.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen gestellt.
Okay, ich habe ein paar Fragen gestellt.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Ist die Frage sehr wichtig?
Ist der Schuss auf den Atempunkt?
Wenn man sich auf den Schuss befindet,
dann denkt man eher auf Neokartinfarktus.
Aber wenn man sich auf den Schuss befindet,
dann denkt man eher auf Emboli.
Okay, ich habe es verstanden.
Ich erinnere mich nicht, aber ich denke,
wenn man auf den Schuss befindet,
dann denkt man eher auf Neokartinfarktus.
Ja, wenn man sich auf den Schuss befindet,
dann denkt man eher auf Herzinfarktus.
Aber ich habe es nicht so gut verstanden.
Deswegen habe ich es gefragt.
Okay, ich habe es richtig verstanden.
Ist das Anglia Pictoris?
Das ist eigentlich Emboli.
Ich habe es verstanden.
Anglia Pictoris muss ein typisches Schuss sein,
das nicht an den Schuss befindet,
sondern an den Schuss befindet.
Ich habe es nicht in den Schuss befindet,
weil die meisten nicht wissen.
Du hast gestern mit Romatoid Artiste gesprochen.
Er ist ein Freund.
Romatoid, Romatoche, Fiba,
er ist auch Romatoche, Artist.
Das weiß niemand.
Ich habe in Gruppen gesehen,
dass niemand weiß.
Und dass niemand von diesem Freund ist.
Die meisten der anderen kennen nicht.
Und es gibt generell schlechte Fakten.
Es gibt mehr Menschen, die schlechte Fakten haben.
Wenn du die Menschen nicht beantworten kannst,
dann wirst du sie nicht beantworten.
Aber in diesem Fall kannst du sie nicht beantworten.
Du kannst sie immer wieder beantworten.
Auch in der Akute MS-Konzentration.
Denn Akute MS-Konzentration hat auch Pummel und Emboli.
Aber wenn du diese Faktoren nicht beantworten kannst,
Wenn du nicht die Fragen der Anwesenden beantworten kannst, wirst du leider nicht mehr da.
Nicht weil du dich nicht kennst, sondern weil du die Fragen nicht beantworten kannst.
Verstanden.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das ist wichtig.
Man muss es schon in einer anderen Weise fragen.
Die MI-Tabelle in der Kolonne ist klassisch.
Es wird Durkund, es wird die Wurzeln, es wird eine Schmerzkussung, es wird sehr stark.
Pummel und Rheinbrüder werden stark.
Aber Pummel und Rheinbrüder werden nicht so stark.
Das ist ein Australen.
Deswegen müssen wir uns etwas von der MI-Tabelle ein bisschen weiter von den Möbeln heran.
Was kann ein Schmerzstück sein?
Vielleicht ist ein Trauma, vielleicht ist ein Schmerz verfallen.
Vielleicht ist es Phenomotorax oder Pummel und Rheinbrüder.
Pummel und Rheinbrüder sind schon zu Beginn ein Emboli.
Die Anwesenden müssen sich ein bisschen fühlen, wo die Anwesenden auf die andere Seite hin sollen.
Ich habe es sehr gut gefühlt.
Ich habe mich zuerst so entspannt gefühlt, dass ich nicht mehr atme.
Ich habe mich da so entspannt gefühlt.
Dann war ich dann auch so entspannt, dass ich nicht mehr so entspannt war.
Wie immer.
Wie die vorherigen.
Ja, wie die vorherigen.
Kann ich etwas sagen?
Ja, bitte.
Wenn du die Anwesenden sofort in die Pflege heranbringen willst,
muss man erst einmal die Name des Anwesenden nennen.
Natürlich.
Ja, ja.
Man muss zumindest die Name nennen und dann die Prognosen machen.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Ja, das habe ich schon gesagt.
Du solltest die Name nennen.
Und ob deine Mutter eine Allergien hat, für welche Medikamente.
Du solltest sie unbedingt nennen und dann in die Pflege sein.
Du solltest die Anwesenden nennen.
Wer ist das?
Wer ist das, der das alles tun kann?
Wenn du eine Not unter dir hättest,
würden wir nicht so schnell ausgehen.
Was?
Entschuldigung, ich habe eine andere Anwesenden geöffnet.
Sie sind auf der falschen Seite.
Entschuldigung.
Ich habe die Stimme vergessen.
Entschuldigung, ich bin verabschiedet.
Ich lese die Stimme von Ferit ab.
Ja.
Okay.
Wenn du bereit bist.
Es ist nicht so schlimm, dass du das nicht in der Simulation gemacht hast.
Aber im Test muss man lernen, wie man sich im Embolleur befindet.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, die Verwaltungen bleiben mit den ersten Verwaltungen.
Die anderen werden schon wissen.
Es gibt Protokolle, die du tun musst.
Es gibt auch Tipps, die du im Test machen musst.
Wenn du das machst, dann wirst du im Test gehen.
Aber wenn die seltenen Verwaltungen auf den Boden kommen,
musst du auch bereit sein.
Ja, im Eingang, wenn du erst die Nennung nennst,
dann die Nennung, die du nennst,
ist das nicht 20 Minuten?
Ich glaube, es ist 15 Minuten.
Wir haben 15 Minuten.
Ich kann es 20 Minuten nennen.
Aber 15 Minuten ist besser.
Wie lange nennst du das?
Ich kann es 20 Minuten nennen.
Okay, 20 Minuten nenne ich.
Wie du willst.
Okay, 15 Minuten.
Guten Tag, Herr Dr. Obaaz.
Ich habe einen neuen Patent aufgenommen.
Ich würde ihn gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich.
Der 59-jährige Herr Alfred Bruch ist 1,79 Meter groß
und wiegt 105 Kilogramm.
Herr Bruch stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit einer Stunde bestehenden,
erstmaligen Stechenden, plötzlich Auftretenden,
Brustschmerzen, Thoraxschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Die Schmerzen legen bei 8 von 10 auf eine Schmerzskala
und es gäbe als Auslöser körperliche Belastung.
Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen gemacht?
Ja, ich habe schon den Patent,
die Vitaparameter gemessen, monitorisiert
und Sauerstoff gegeben.
Sauerstoff gegeben?
Haben Sie schon Blut abgenommen?
EKG geschrieben?
Ja, EKG haben wir schon gemacht.
Wir haben schon den Patent monitorisiert.
Einen Eingang haben wir auch schon eingelegt
und Blut haben wir auch abgenommen.
Was meinen Sie mit Vitaparameter?
Welche Parameter haben Sie schon kontrolliert?
Also den Puls, den Blutdruck, Puls und Fieber.
Und Sauerstoffsättigung.
Danke schön. Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen gegeben?
Welche Medikamente?
Wir haben Blut abgenommen, die Dimmabrachung hat sich erhöht
und deswegen haben wir Heparin verabreicht.
Gut gemacht. Weiter machen.
Leidet er unter Thesis?
Ja, er leidet seit einer Stunde unter Blutthesis.
Blutthesis, ok.
Ja, Blutthesis.
Weiter machen bitte.
Zu dem Thorac-Schmerzen begleitet er Dispne, wie ich schon gesagt habe Blutthesis,
Tachikardie, Palpitationsschwinde, Kälteschwitze und blaue Lippen.
Blaue Lippen.
Er wurde von seinen Kollegen hierher gebracht.
Die Kollegen haben ihm gesagt, dass seine Lippen blau sind.
Ist ihm schwindelig geworden?
Ja, er sei schwindelig geworden.
Gut.
Und außer einer Stunde bestehender Inappetenz ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Gibt es Begründerausschlüsse?
Ja, körperliche Belastung. Während er die Treppen aufsteige, haben die Beschwerden aufgetreten.
Ist er länger im Mobil? Lange Reise, Betrug?
Ja, er sei vor vier Wochen aufgrund von rechten Unterschenkelfraktoren operiert worden.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Risikofaktor.
Ja, auch der Faktor. Wegen dieser Operation sei er eine Woche lang stationär aufgenommen und eine Woche lang zu Hause im Betrug.
Hat der Patient Antigagulantherapie nach der Entlassung eingenommen?
Besonders danach habe ich mich gefragt. Aber außer der Medikamente, die er wegen seiner chronischen Erkrankungen einnehme, und nur eine Salbe, habe er nichts Weiteres eingegeben.
Hat er Schmerzen oder Schwierigkeiten in den Beinen?
Er hat Schwierigkeiten, aber sehr leichte Schmerzen. Keine Überwärmung, keine Color und keine Rubor.
Es besteht keine Color und Color und Rubor.
Gibt es andere Beschützungen in der Vorgeschichte?
Ja, als Vorerkrankungen leidet er an arteriöler Hypertonie seit sieben Jahren.
Er nimmt dagegen Betalogsock, 25 mg, einmal abends. Er leidet auch an Diabetes Militus seit zwei Jahren.
Ist der Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Ich denke schon, aber besonders habe ich nicht gefragt. Das kann ich während der körperlichen Untersuchung fragen.
Ja, okay.
Gut eingestellt.
Noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, er leidet auch an Diabetes Militus seit zwei Jahren und er nimmt dagegen Janovia, 100 mg, einmal morgens.
Beide chronische Krankheiten sind Kritsikofaktoren für eine Gerinnungsstörung.
Also nicht direkt, aber indirekt schon.
Allergien?
Es sind keine Allergien bekannt, aber er raucht seit 30 Jahren 35 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Gibt es in seiner Familie Gerinnungsstörungen?
Seine Mutter hat in ihren 60er Jahren an einer TvT gelitten.
Ich habe TvT gedacht nach den Angaben in den 60er Jahren.
Sein Vater ist im Alter von 79 Jahren an einem Myokasinfarkt gestorben.
Okay. Und ist es eine soziale Amnese? Gibt es irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten?
Nein, es gibt keine. Er ist verheiratet neben seiner Familie zusammen, hat drei gesunde Kinder
und arbeitet als Büroangestellter.
Büroangestellter? Ja.
Okay. Und seit wann ist der Patient unarbeitfähig?
Seit zwei Wochen arbeitet er nach der Operation.
Nach der Operation seit zwei Wochen ist er arbeitsfähig.
Okay. Und wie würden Sie vergessen?
Also wir haben schon den Patienten Vitalparameter gemessen und wir müssen den Lungen und den Herz abhören.
Wir haben schon Blut abgenommen und die Gerinnungsfaktoren bestimmt.
Und man kann auch ein Blutbild und den Entzündungsparameter kontrollieren.
Wir haben schon den Patienten monitorisiert.
Okay. Und welche Diagnose haben Sie?
Also die Anamneseangaben deuten am besten auf eine Lungenembolie.
Ja gut. Und als Differenzialdiagnostik kommen eine Myokasinfarkt,
und Pneumonie, vielleicht Pneumothorax in Betracht.
Okay. Welche Parameter oder welche Laborparameter würden Sie bestimmen lassen?
Also im Blut. Also die Dimmer, um die Gerinnungsfaktoren in der INR.
Und um eine Herzkrankheit auszuschließen, muss man Troponin, CKMB auch bestimmen.
Um eine Pneumonie auszuschließen, müssen wir die Entzündungsparameter bestimmen.
Ja, die kommen jetzt. Die verfolgen wir jetzt ein.
Und Bilgebendesverfahren?
Also Röntgen-Torax, EKG und Eko-Kardiographie und Duplex-Sonographie an den gespollenen Beinen.
Okay. Eko-Kardiographie.
Ja, Eko-Kardiographie und ja auch eine Duplex-Sonographie.
Gut. Und Therapie?
Also als Therapie würde ich also eine gerinnungslösende Therapie durchführen mit Heparin.
Welche Medikamente oder welche Therapie würden Sie sofort einleiten?
Sofort, also Heparin?
Gut, ja.
Ja, Heparin.
Muss man direkt Heparin einleiten?
Ja. Also nur Heparin würde reichen, denke ich.
Ja.
Okay. Heparin, so.
Ja, und nach der Entlassung als vorbeugende Therapie vielleicht Aspirin oder Clopidogrel.
Gut.
Oder beide zusammen.
Was ist der Goldstandard zur Diagnosestellung der Lungeneboi?
Goldstandard CT, Thorax CT.
Angeographie. CT. Ja, Thorax CT Angeographie.
Thorax CT Angeographie.
Ja, gut.
Ja, ja, okay.
Okay. Sie haben schon erklärt, aber ich möchte nochmal hören.
Was ist die wichtigste Sofortmaßnahme?
In der Notaufnahme.
Also bei diesem Patienten oder generell? Also natürlich bei diesem Patienten.
Generell.
Wenn Sie eine Verdachtdiagnose auf Kummer, Embolle haben, was ist die wichtigste Sofortmaßnahme?
Okay, also wir müssen erst den Patienten monitorisieren und die Sauerstoff messen.
Die Vitalpyramide müssen wir gleichzeitig messen, eine Zugang einlegen, ein Blut abnehmen und auch Blutgasanalyse machen.
Und ja, nach der Blutabnehmung, falls wir die Gerinnungsstörung festgestellt haben, gleichzeitig mit Therapie anfangen.
Würden Sie diesen Patienten stationäre Aufnahme empfehlen?
Ja, ja, stationär würde ich einigen.
Intensivstation.
Ja, Intensivstation.
Okay.
Sauerstoffseidokumenten überprüfen und EKG schreiben. Ja, ja, das sind wichtig und haben wir schon gemacht.
Ja, die anderen Sachen müssen nicht gefragt werden.
Wenn Sie einen Patienten oder eine EMA für einen Pulmonerembol haben, dann monitorieren Sie ihn sofort.
Wie ist das?
Dann monitorieren Sie den Patienten sofort, ein IV-Zugang, ein Legen, eine Vitalpyramide kontrollieren.
Dann starten Sie sofort Antikaglan-Tätigungen für Pulmonerembol.
Wenn Sie nicht wüssten, dann machen Sie eine Heparin-Hintravenose.
Vor dem Tätigungen? Also vor dem Kastoffen?
Ja, das ist nicht wüsten.
Was kann man sagen?
Sie bekommen jetzt einen Stoff und geben eine Blutverdünnetherapie.
Wenn Sie sagen, dass Sie so etwas gesagt haben, dann können Sie sagen, dass Sie nicht in der Testung waren.
Dann können Sie sagen, dass Sie Blutverdünnetherapie beginnen oder Sie werden von den Ergebnissen von Y-Nahtem, Ergapnis, Köntem, Blutverdünnetherapie, Einleitung, etc.
Aber wenn Sie einen Pulmonerembol haben, dann machen Sie eine EMA und ein IV-Zugang.
Dann sagen Sie dem Patienten, dass Sie einen Pulmonerembol haben und Sie mit einer Heparin-Hintravenose beginnen.
Das zeigt, dass Sie mit dem Patienten in der EMA beginnen können.
Sie wissen, dass Sie mit Pulmonerembolen Heparin-Hintravenose beginnen.
Sie fragen Sie nicht, warum Sie Heparin-Hintravenose haben müssen.
EMA ist eine Monotherapie.
Sie sind ein bisschen wie Monoha-Therapie.
Ich verstehe.
Sie werden die EMA schon machen.
Sie haben gut Zeit, weil Sie keine Sprache haben.
Sie können das auch schnell sagen.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen, um ein paar Parameter zu kontrollieren.
Ich meine damit, dass ich troponin habe.
Oder Sie können sagen, Sie werden ein paar Parameter von Labors kontrollieren.
Sie können die EMA und den Patienten sagen, warum Sie Blut abnehmen.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, können Sie eine kurze Beweise machen.
Wie Herr Ayko gesagt hat.
Sie können die EMA und die Heparin-Hintravenose beantworten.
Ich habe eine Frage von mir, die ich gestern nicht getroffen habe.
Ein anderer hat sie gefragt.
Ich habe sie mir auch beantwortet.
Sie können die EMA und den Patienten sagen, wenn Sie einen Fehler haben.
Ich habe sie im Test gemacht.
Sie haben sie alle ok gemacht.
Aber wenn Sie Zeit haben, können Sie die EMA und die Heparin-Hintravenose beantworten.
Sie können die EMA und den Patienten sagen, warum Sie die Heparin-Hintravenose beantworten.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, können Sie die EMA und den Patienten sagen, wenn Sie eine Veränderung haben.
Sie können die EMA und den Patienten sagen, wenn Sie Zeit haben, können Sie die Heparin-Hintravenose beantworten.
Ich kann dir etwas fragen, ob ich mich im Beklemmen bewegen kann.
Natürlich.
Du hast die Tension gut ausgestattet.
Darüber müssen wir uns fragen, ob es eine Schäkertension gibt oder ob du den Doktor
regelmäßig besuchen möchtest.
Ich bin nicht derjenige, der das nicht macht.
Ich bin derjenige, der das nicht macht.
Okay, das zweite.
Ich habe jetzt gesagt, dass ich Herzreise habe.
Ich kann das als Testschatzkarte nennen.
Sehera, du oder Hatip?
Du hast es heute auch gesagt.
Können wir das sagen?
Nein, nein.
Was ist das für eine Diuretik?
Ja, ja.
Tensionentzündung, ja.
Ich bin nicht sicher, ob es eine Diuretik-Effektivität oder Diuretik-Effektivität hat.
Diese Medikamente machen den Kopfschmerz.
Wir hatten eine Behandlung.
Die Patientin hat einen Kopfschmerz.
Sie haben in der Aztgeistbreche gefragt, warum sie einen Kopfschmerz hat.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat Hydrochlorothiazit.
Sie hat gesagt, dass es eine Erklärung für den Kopfschmerz hat.
Ich habe mir das erinnern können.
Ich habe sie gesagt.
Die Kommission kann dir manchmal ein bisschen zusätzliche Informationen geben.
So wie der Professor Hayk.
Nicht um dich zu lassen, sondern um dir, als Physiker,
die Behandlung von etwas zu machen.
Wenn du dir nicht die Erklärung für Hydrochlorothiazit nennst,
dann hast du keine Ahnung.
Aber manchmal sagen sie dir, dass du das auch machen musst.
Sie benutzen Hydrochlorothiazit.
Sie machen das erfolgreich.
Sie geben diese Informationen.
Aber das ist nicht so.
Wenn du Kardiolog bist oder dich mit der-Branche interessiert,
dann werden sie dich fragen.
Wenn du nicht von der-Branche bist, dann ist das eine sehr schreckliche Frage.
Das stimmt.
Die Frau ist wahrscheinlich Kardiolog.
Sie hat sie auch dazu gebeten, dass sie zusätzliche Informationen geben kann.
Ich verstehe, dass es nicht viel zu tun ist.
Ich verstehe, dass es keine sehr große Probleme gibt.
Aber wenn du eine MI-Tabelle hast,
dann musst du dir die Monoha-Therapie sagen.
Oder wenn du eine Pulmonary Embolle hast,
dann musst du dir die Kommission zeigen, wie du das machen kannst.
Aber wenn du eine Podogra hast,
dann kannst du dir die Podogra sagen.
Das ist nicht wichtig, wenn du das nicht weißt.
Oder ob du Allopurinol geben willst oder nicht.
Wie du das geben willst, wie viel Dosen es gibt,
300 mg oder halb.
Aber die anderen Dinge sind nicht sehr wichtig.
Denn es ist kein Wissenschaftsprozess.
Aber wir müssen uns die Dinge zeigen, die wir wissen.
Aber wir müssen die Dinge zeigen, die wir wissen.
Ich verstehe, du sagst das richtig.
Aber wenn du diese kleinen Schriften auch weißt,
Dann sind sie natürlich in deinem Geist.
dann sind sie nicht in deinem Geist.
Sie denken, dass sie in deinem Geist sind.
Ich habe eine Freundin von mir,
die mir die Simulation gemacht hat.
Sie ist leider nicht da.
Wir haben gestern gesprochen,
aber sie weiß nicht,
warum sie das nicht weiß.
Sie weiß nicht, warum sie die Schriften nicht weiß.
Wenn du die Schriften nicht weißt,
dann ist es nicht so wichtig,
dass du sie nicht weißt.
Wenn du die Schriften nicht weißt,
dann ist es nicht so wichtig,
dass du sie nicht weißt.
Denn die Schriften sind wichtig.
Ich habe auch in den Protokollen geschrieben,
dass ich nicht weiss,
ich bin nicht we severity und in der Kirche sind auch야지 die Schriften auch.
Ich habe gesagt,
dass siearshall Foundationsinhalte sind.
Die Schriften können wir nicht im uneasy.
Ich weiß nicht, von der Schrifteneineighb가든,
dass es hier nicht wäre.
Ich weiß auch nicht,
einzelne Schriften發len würden.
Ich tue diese Schriften.
Wenn wir die Patienten verlassen, wird er sagen, dass er gehen wird.
Das ist wichtig. Das ist auch eine Kommunikation.
Da sagen sie, dass die Patientin die ersten zwei, drei Minuten nicht aufhört, was sie sagt.
Aber sie legt die Zeit ab.
Das ist wichtig.
Es ist wichtig, dass die Patientin die erste, vier Minuten nicht aufhört.
Denn die Patientin muss die Zeit abhören.
Das ist das Problem.
Bei den Testen sind es fast 5 Minuten.
Bei den Testen sind es fast 1 in 4 Minuten.
Wenn du siehst, dass die Patientin sich aufhört,
dann geht es um unvergessliche Dinge.
Die Patientin sagt, dass sie sich aufhört.
Sie hat schon in dieser Zeit eine neue Anlage gemacht.
Sie sagt ihr Problem.
Sie sagt, dass sie sich unvergessliche Dinge nicht aufhört.
Aber wenn du siehst, dass du es hast, dann muss man sich aufhören.
Ich bin nicht interessiert um diese Themen zu erzählen.
Aber wenn ich das sprechen kann, dann kann ich es auch.
Das kann man dann sagen.
Ja, das ist ein kleiner Tipp.
Interessieren sich für.
Das ist nicht über.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich habe keine Kontraktion.
Ich bin mit allen überlebt.
Interessieren sich für.
Ja, interessieren sich.
Interessieren mich.
Ich interessiere mich.
Oder da für.
Du hast gesagt, dass du nicht interessiert bist.
Da für.
Ja.
Jeden Abend um 11 Uhr.
Okay, inşallah.
Bis bald.